secretary mayorkas does not resign
House Republicans will investigate every
order
every action
and every failure
will determine whether we can begin
impeachment inquiry
that was House minority leader Kevin
McCarthy making his message to the
administration pretty clear during his
visit to the Texas border now the
Department of Homeland Security is
responding saying quote members of
Congress can do better than point
fingers at someone else that should come
to the table and work on solutions for
our broken system and outdated laws
which have not been overhauled in over
40 years here to react Tom Holman Fox
News contributor retired acting ice
director Tom so the Republicans are
making their Red Line very clear and
they want to host uh meetings at the
border sessions at the border to make
this a big issue do you think it's going
to work
well I think the oversight hearings
would definitely work and look guys like
me who's been around for 35 years we
will tell them who to subpoena what
information you want requested in that
subpoena and where you can find that
information because when they do
oversight hearings there's going to be a
lot of damning information that comes
out that's going to put my orcas in a
very bad spot and it's going to force
them to resign so I I salute my car
through to doing this and and I can't
wait for it to begin because mallorcas
has violated the oath office he's taken
and he his re his actions On the Border
have failed as you know Lawrence every
month a record number he has failed for
18 months time for him to go well Tom I
made this point on the five last night
the board is the scene of a crime they
need to see what happens there take them
to the Big Bend sector where they can
smell the bodies that are rotten you
know they're there but you can't find
them because they're all over the place
they need to see what these children
that are drowning how about they drain
drained uh um the Rio Grande so they can
see how many bodies that are buried
there how about they go to one of those
semi trucks and stay in there for three
minutes so they can see what they're
encouraging the illegal migrants to do
yeah and if I thought you're going to
see a single Democrat Congressman do
that they ran down to the border under
President Trump when two children died
now we got over 1400 Microsoft died in
U.S soil where are they where's
Congressman Castro where's Congress
congresswoman AOC who went down there
screaming on the Trump Administration
they're ignoring the clear data if you
look at the department statement they
put out saying they're going to continue
to support the workforce let's remember
he's not supporting the workforce he
took a federal law enforcement agency
and turned him in a tourist agency
because they're not enforcing law the
process of people releasing people
taking them to an airport and flying to
a city of their choice and not only that
he stood at the White House Podium and
slandered the men and women of the horse
Patrol when he knew they were innocent
he needs to go he has no respect in the
workforce the workforce has no respect
in him it's unbelievable uh Tom another
thing I wanted to get you to react to
according to the Boston uh Herald the
Biden Administration is set to deploy
Air Marshal to the border to help with
migrants Wednesday I mean what are they
doing
why they need Air Marshals he just said
the board is secure the board is closed
why you need more people down there I'll
tell you why they're sending more people
down there to process quicker and
release quicker because they don't want
the Optics of overcrowding because if
they don't have what we're crowding
there's not an issue my orcasian keep
lying to the American people that the
board is secure he isn't sending one
officer down there to enforce the law
and secure the Border he's sending him
there to process quicker release quicker
so he can control the Optics of this
crisis this is this is this is insulting
to the American people again needs to be
impeached I've called for it for over a
year I'm glad Congress has finally
taking some action we'll see what
happens Tom Holmen thanks so much
brother